vous est ce que pouvait donner trois
conseils coiffure pour les personnes qui
nous regardent
voilà non mais excuse moi tu crois qu'on
fait des missions pour eux l'un
des jours les brouillards juste avant
l'été
pour avoir le cheveu pas parce que moi
j'ai souvent l'été justement le cheveu
sec mais ce que je pourrais prendre le
vent de la mer parce que on va reparler
du cilq engine chez kérastase
pour gérer blosne paraît que c'est pas
mal ce qu'ils font non si je laisse si
vous allez au soleil à plein il y en a
pour tous les gars là pour tous les
goûts et y en a pour toutes les bourses
a ouvert le 12 mai mais vous pouvez le
mieux c'est de partir avec des sérums
filtre à uv des choses comme ça qui vont
protéger ses rangs le soleil et les
trahisons mais sur les bus voilà qui
vont protéger du soleil qui vont
protéger la couleur et qui vont
continuer à les hydrater le e malgré les
médias la répétition sur n'a pas de
couleur si on n'a pas de couleur aussi
ça fonctionne c'est ramos albiol
fonctionne un peu plus sur la banane
donc je mets ça j'aimerais ça ouais je
mets quoi chemin petit sérum un petit
sérum filtre uv pour m'a parlé du
moonlight
et laboratoires chaud ce kof
je sais bien
est ce que pour l'été tu penses que moi
je moi je sais je me pose beaucoup de
questions
si tu sais aujourd'hui voilà je suis
extrêmement convoité
en toute humilité qu'est ce que je dois
faire cet été capillairement
gms qui doit laisser pousser ou pas
alors fait les séduit le moment de
tenter les expériences un petit peu
folle donc en gros les filles c'est le
moment vous à l'éclaircie enfin des
balayages et tout ça et les garçons
c'est le moment de couper peut-être un
peu plus courts d'avoir découvert un
petit peu folle parce que pour la
rentrée quand tu vas retourner au boulot
il faudra des coupures on en a pas un
vrai loup douvres oui mais bon c'est pas
non plus des morceaux tu vois pas aussi
tu as envie de tenter la décoloration
les 2 3 et la tchèque et j'avais envie
de faire un blanc polaire
mais comme dit la couleur des guillaume
nom de gi oh c'est pas un blanc polaire
guillaume c'est très beau et jeune homme
en colère est-ce que vous pensez que
s'il devrait laisser tomber l'animation
et se consacrer pleinement au
mannequinat
vu le physique franchement sur d été et
que vous voulez ma place
on va où nicolas je vais vous appelez
jonathan
l'avocat de jonathan vous avez des
choses à table il faut quand même dire
que la décoloration s'abîmer cheveux
alors oui la bible les cheveux non
vraiment ici c'est très bien et oui
aujourd'hui à des produits de dengue et
c'est vraiment on doit des sous pour ça
mais après tu as les
cheveux si tu vas n'importe où oui ça va
c'est vrai alors il faut faire attention
à vous faire très attention mais elle
est produite mais des produits
aujourd'hui à ph 1
non
il ya des décolorations maintenant
qu'ils sont tellement puissantes qu'on
peut mettre à faible oxydation et sava
décolorés tranquillement mais sûrement
et ça n'abîme pas les cheveux j'aimerais
plus blanc j'aimerais bien voir et ce
plus blanc alors oui tu as le connard
je le mets ailleurs le talk 1
[Musique]
owen qui sur la lourdeur
fait une mauvaise voie non plus s'ils
ratent le gel
des fonds comme une couche flamber
alors qu'aujourd'hui il ya de plus en
plus de femmes qui mettent des
extensions et et je vois de plus en plus
de femmes qui perdent leurs cheveux à
cause de ça à cause de l'extension à
coder les extensions alors ça dépend ça
dépend de la pause aujourd'hui à plein
d'extension différentes ya des
extensions il ya des têtes donc c'est
d'expression un petit peu autocollantes
qu'on peut enceintes ayant des clips
c'est comme des clips mais c'est
vraiment des bandes adhésives exactement
les enlever il ya des six roms pour les
enlever sa vraie dans la pâtisserie ne
suis pas pas le poids des textos sont
d'accord c'est bien ça va mais ça se
voit après tout
non sur les faits mais après tout c'est
d'être mal coiffée oui tout se voit et
ça me faut s'enlever non pour l'été il
vaut mieux tout enlever si on a des ex
la dépense ça dépend il ya des femmes et
amber heard et l'extension de leurs
soins des attaches pour avoir été à
bientôt rajouter un petit clip mois par
mois parfois
[Musique]
j'aime ce soir avec mes potes ajoute un
petit clip ici
recommanderiez à cyril parce qu'il
s'interrogeait ce en raison des matches
comme ça pour l'été ouais ben si c'est
un drop c'est bien la petite raie sur le
côté à moi je crois la retraite conclut
le sens
mais c'est normal pas mal c'est pas mal
non c'est très joli ça oui madame oui
pour les blondes souvent dans la piscine
avec le chlore que ça peut devenir un
peu bleus
pas dans la piscine nous fais pas çi
alors ben justement
pour passer de viale vers envoya plus un
truc à vous savez les cacher comment
apprécier l'aspirine oui ben sassi
vraiment à un forfait vertu trempe ses
cheveux dans attendu
sagement le même forfait spa toute
sérénité comme à ce site et donc je
m'étais chevaux dans le mall ketchup
attaqué le ketchup ou non mais faut pas
que j'avais gens prêtent déjà
beaucoup alors c'est ou du ketchup ou de
ou de décevoir c'est à dire que tu es
tranquillement avec tam a tué chalet
[Rires]
j'ai ma couleur qui part en cacahuète
merci d'un récent débat et vous rendez
compte c'est vrai que tu es comme un
reflet têtu mais
c'est un truc de fou oui est ce que le
maire c'est mauvais pour les cheveux
est-ce qu'il faut forcément se rincer
les cheveux après s'être baigné dans
l'eau de mer alors moi je dirais non
passe quelque chose que c'est génial la
lecture des cheveux avec l'eau de mer ça
tient un petit post guen ça ça gratte
mais ça
c'est pas dit oui à l'abus de pistils de
soleil et tout ça c'est pour ça qu'il
faut les soigner un petit peu entre les
deux séries quand on a l'eau de mer
comme ça vaut mieux les laver le moins
possible même si on garde le sébum c'est
le meilleur série claude soulez la grèce
un petit peu et en bande aristo qui
restent il raté mais quand même quelques
années que ça irrite juste en dessus 9
le maillot t ça frotte comme ça où
travaille le matin et le matin
mais c'est vrai tu te réveilles le matin
est un espèce de variole
testicules et remettent ça mais c'est
vrai qu'en général il faut prendre une
douche ce soir voyait
mal à prendre la douche mais fergie
will faute en poney avec une serviette
et bien c'est parce que cet employé
comme je suis très d'accord moi je vois
tu voir ce que je peux faire
mais est ce que il faut parce que l'été
on a tendance à beaucoup se laver les
cheveux et moi j'avais lu qui fait qu'on
pouvait aussi alterner un vrai shampoing
et juste un après-shampooing parfois
parce qu'ils évitent et franchement
l'été c'est les laver deux fois par
semaine daignez donc
la dernière fois j'avais pu dire ça va
enlever le sébum donc il faut garder un
peu de ces bugs c'est vachement après
shampoing de temps en temps
n est pas dans ton salon là
j'ai dit qu elle adopte
moi je sais pas me servir de l'après
shampoing ma tête me
rappelle jean oui mais c'est la
jeune fille a
bien passé
mais je n'y fais gaffe paient la gueule
mais toi mais toi t'as plus rien à faire
pour toi j'ai une question pour les gens
qui font beaucoup de bateaux et avec le
vent a tourné les mandats d'un gros
bateau donc est-ce que c'est mauvais
pour le pour les cheveux pour ce faire
attention au retour dans la cabine par
exemple matin à l'abri il faut toujours
j'ai dit ça pour un copain à moi qui
pars en mai
[Rires]
je son goût de lac de lalla tient là
mais
non mais non mais là il faut mettre de
la voie lactée pour lignes on ne
connaissait pas faire allez on y va
madame boudarène jouer
c'est batman belle-fille bas ça bouge à
peine
[Rires]
pour madame boutin
vous êtes magnifique regard des aubaines
envie vous avez déjà aubergines
musulmane et si
oui mais la famille m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient déjoué moussa câble
cette réponse à la bouteille
là ces personnes là
non mais c'est vrai on attend la laque
moi j'aurai le choix rappelle cnn est
oui
les corps sont eux mais de l'aele net
faire donc c'est que tu as pris dans la
violer
we had meuf qui te fait eux enfin
l'équipe mais là comme ça premier c'est
que tu es devenu il ya un deuxième bail
chez le coiffeur j'ai jamais pris qu'on
sait qu'à un moment le coiffeur à la fin
efficace il prend un autre et
il fait jusqu'à
sa mort
[Applaudissements]